this is a production of Cornell
University
so I really appreciate the opportunity
to talk about the life sciences core
laboratory center in terms of my
background I'm a molecular biologist I
came to Cornell about five years ago now
from the Harvard Medical School where I
helped set up and run the first genome
Center at Harvard so my expertise is in
genomics part of the Human Genome
Project the mouse genome project a lot
of home microbial whole genome assembly
type projects as well as in
translational research so coming to
Cornell was really eye-opening to me in
terms of all the types of applications
that you can do in both agriculture and
veterinary sciences so I'm going to be
talking about the the various
technologies in the life sciences core
laboratory center as well as some of the
ways you might be able to access and
know about some of the other shared
research resources at Cornell so I'll
start off with an introduction to the
life sciences core laboratory Center
which for sure we typically just called
the CLC so it's currently composed of
seven life sciences core laboratories
it's open to all investigators at
Cornell University and to outside
investigators it was established a while
ago as part of the new life sciences
initiative it's a part of a new york
state designated center for advanced
technology and it's administered by the
institute for biotechnology and life
sciences technology jos rose is the
director of the what's typically called
the biotech Institute now the mission of
the cemetery is to promote research in
the life sciences with advanced
technologies in a shared resource
environment the center includes fee for
services research technology testing and
development and the educational
components so these are the seven core
facilities that currently compose the
center so we have a genomics facility we
have they are a number of first
generation sequencing instruments the
ABI 3730
capillary electrophoresis instruments
we're doing more than 500,000 samples a
year for that and i should say the
Mandate of the center is to be of
university-wide value so that means that
as you all know corn president we've got
the Ithaca campus with the big focus in
the agricultural and veterinary sciences
the medical school campus the wild
cornell medical college in new york city
and the medical school campus in the
middle east in doha qatar and our center
received samples from all three campuses
in addition as i had mentioned we're a
new york state part of a new york state
designated center for advanced
technologies which means new york state
companies that use us get a discount
that's transparent to us it's subsidized
by New York State and in addition to
that we provide resources and services
for about 100 academic and commercial
institutions in about 40 states in the
United States and about a dozen
countries outside the United States so
that's the scope of our operations so on
in addition to the first generation
sequencing we also have a number of
second generation sequencing instruments
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that in a minute but we have the Rose
454 GS flex and the alumina GA 2x and
alumina hi seek 2000 instruments we also
have a number of genotyping instruments
the the sequin Oh master ray and the
aluminum bead state beat express and we
have a number of different microarray
based platforms from affymetrix from
alumina from nimblegen and from Agilent
so in addition to the genomics facility
we also have an epigenomics facility now
the epigenomics facility is really the
first example that i know of a true
cross campus core a lot of the
infrastructure is located on the medical
school campus and
we also have a lot of the infrastructure
located on the Ithaca campus so this
court provides the the IP the
immunoprecipitations for trip chip and
chip seek and also provides a sample
preparation for any type of math seek
type of application so in addition to
the genomics and epigenomics facility we
have a proteomics and mass spec facility
so this facility provides a number of
different mass spec instruments a we
have a ABI forth out 4700 maldito Tov
and we have a number of electrons spray
instruments including the ABI 4000 cute
wrap the water sin app and the latest
orbitrap from from thermo the V lows so
this core is doing protein
identification post translational
modification based studies and small
molecule characterization ah it's in
addition we have a very high-end imaging
facility so this facility provides
everything from conventional confocal
fluorescence my kasbah see it provides a
whole animal fluorescence imaging a
high-resolution ultrasound and both
micro and nano CT and I'll go into a
little bit more detail about that as
well particularly how that can impact
some significant projects in plant
biology and i should say we're also
working on building up our own
multiphoton microscopy so to provide
support for all these cores that can
give you a real fire hose of data we
have a very high-end bioinformatics
facility we call it the computational
biology service unit or the CBS you this
core has a lot of infrastructure we've
got a cluster with more than a thousand
cpus and we have a very close
relationship with microsoft we're one of
only ten worldwide microsoft designated
high performance computing institutes so
the corp has leveraged a Microsoft
funding into building a open-source
portal for life sciences application in
a high-performance computing environment
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that but basically we have more than 50
to livescience's applications in this
portal including next-generation
sequencing pipelines that's available to
everyone at Cornell and the other area
of expertise of this bioinformatics core
is building up basically bio IT limbs
information management systems that
combined all the different types of
information you might get from any of
these basic resource portals research a
type of instrumentation and combine it
with the clinic of with the phenotyping
as well so and the the bioinformatics
facility has also had a big focus now in
terms of training in workshops that's
bribed the tools for faculty students
and staff to utilize the analytical
tools we also have a very high end by
oyt facility that's bio information
technology facility so this court
provides all the laboratory information
management systems the limbs for all
these pores for tracking of sample
submission process tracking and data
returned and the core also provides fifa
services for outside academic groups
such as a biomedical engineering and
other academic departments at Cornell so
and finally we have an advanced
technology assessment effort which is
really a way of saying how do we bring
in the new toys to limit so I'm director
of operations of this whole Center so
I'm responsible to be sure everything is
working smoothly and I'm also director
for Advanced Technology Assessment so in
both my areas of expertise in other
areas and in very close collaboration
with the directors of all these cores we
try to determine what are the right new
platforms to bring to Cornell so we
basically listen to you
we listen to what faculty say they need
to be at the cutting edge of research we
try to identify the appropriate
platforms to bring them in for testing
if they look appropriate for our
high-throughput production pipelines we
try to identify sources of funding to
acquire these new platforms and once we
have them we try to further kick the
tires to optimize applications on these
new platforms as well as develop new
methods and new techniques to more fully
utilize and optimally utilize new
technologies so basically the core
laboratory Center provides support for
everything from jeans to proteins to uh
to phenotype all tied in together with
the bioinformatics and bio IT now our
first of our cores are located in the
biotech building that's the genomics a
part of the epigenomics the proteomics
and mass back the bed by OT and Advanced
Technology Assessment are all located in
the biotechnology building our
bioinformatics facility is located in
wrote all it's hosted by the CAC the
Cornell Advanced Computing Center and
our imaging core is a lot of the
technologies in the basement of wile
whole it's in a vibration free section
of the basement and we also have various
confocal and other instruments over by
the vet school some of it behind the
animal barriers so one of the things we
try to do by leveraging having so much
multidisciplinary a multi-core expertise
all under one virtual roof is multiple
really integrated multidisciplinary
support for shared research resources so
for example our next-generation
sequencing is located as you might
imagine in our genomics facility and
they're responsible for sample
preparation and data generation and
first pass data quality analysis but if
we have any types of project
which involve epigenomics or high-end
bioinformatics support the or really
developing new types of applications our
epigenomics core or by automatic score
or by OIT and our Advanced Technology
Assessment what cores can all get
involved in terms of the support and
operations of this instrument and i
should say we really sort of have a
systems biology approach to the support
of research projects so if there's
projects that have data that includes
not just genomics but proteomics and
imaging data we at the point of project
design we bring into all the appropriate
core directors to really talk about how
to appropriately integrate all these
data streams into one type of structure
which is appropriate for bioinformatics
analysis and in support of that as i
mentioned our bio informatics core as a
real expertise in developing integrate
integrated databases for step genotyping
gene expression DNA sequencing
proteomics data imaging data and all
integrated with the phenotypic data that
that you might require and they
developed a lot of this expertise in
support of large-scale national plant
projects and have leveraged that it all
the way into supporting clinical based
human based projects just by putting
HIPAA compliance where yeah you know
obviously the plants don't care about
privacy what humans do so I'd like to
talk a little bit about each of the
cores and start off with the genomic so
the types of sequencing technologies
that we have in our core include the ABI
3730 Excel this is a 96 capillary array
electrophoresis instrument it's the
basically the cold standard instrument
for first generation sequencing using
Sanger chemistry and was the instrument
that we actually enabled the Human
Genome Project
a lot of other types of whole genome
assembly type projects so the types of
parameters that I look at when trying to
compare these types of sequencing
technologies are read length number of
reads in parallel the number of bases
you get in the full run the run time /
full run the raw data storage needs in
the cost per full run now there are
other parameters as well how many
samples can you run how much
multiplexing can you do there are a
number of other very important
parameters but just input in terms of
these very basic considerations the ABI
3730 XL produces about 750 bases per
sample you get 96 reads in parallel it
takes about two hours so in about two
hours you get a little bit less than a
hundred thousand bases you can run this
24 7 and the amount of raw data storage
needs is in the megabyte range and the
cost here depending upon whether or not
you're a small scale academic core
facility or a very large-scale genome
center ranges anywhere from fifty
dollars to five hundred dollars for a
full run the very first next-generation
sequencing technology that we brought
into the core was the Roche 454 GS flex
GS referring to genome sequencing
currently well this is actually outdated
this slide we we currently can get 420
bases average read length but we are
upgrading to the latest long read reads
on chemistry on this instrument and that
will enable us to do average read
lengths of anywhere from 650 to 750
basis which really brings it into the
read length range of sanger chemistry
you can get about a million reads in
parallel so with four with about 400
base average read lengths you get about
more than 400 million bases per run
right now we're getting about a Giga
base / run billion bases it takes
about 8 to 12 hours for a single run the
raw data storage needs are in the
gigabyte range and the cost for running
full run depending upon the application
is in the range of now between five to
eight thousand dollars the illumina GA
2x is an older next-generation
sequencing technology was originally
called the celexa instrument and we have
one of these instruments the upgrade to
that is the alumina hi-c 2000 and we
have two of these instruments one which
was just installed about two weeks ago
so with this instrument you can get
about 150 contiguous basis you can also
do pará damn door made and am a pair
type of reeds where you're reading from
the same fragment from from both sides
on you get more than a billion reads in
parallel and currently we get about half
a terabyte worth of bases per run
internally how to luminaire they're
getting of almost a terrible terrible
earth of of a basis per run it takes
about a week depending upon the
applications in the actual read length
that you want to do and such anywhere
from four day 4 to 10 days to do a full
run and the amount of information that
you need to store is actually in the
gigabyte range it actually creates
terabytes worth of data but it doesn't
save everything the data that you really
need to save is it in the gigabyte range
and the cost for running this is in the
range of five to ten thousand dollars
program now the types of applications
you can do on these next-generation
sequencing platforms range the gamut of
just about everything you can imagine
from a whole genome sequencing both de
novo assembly and whole genome
resequencing REE sequencing of PCR a
pecans or other targeted regions of the
genome low frequency mutation detection
genetic variation including both snip
genotyping or copy number variation gene
expression analysis
including whole genome RNA profiling and
i should say this is particularly useful
for looking at degraded RNA from store
examples and also gene regulation based
studies the whole genome small RNA
discovery and quantitation genome-wide
measurements of protein nucleic acid
interactions which is typically called
chip seek and genome-wide DNA
methylation profiling what's typically
called messy based applications on the
454 the this is a picture of the
instrument this is essentially one of
the more expensive type of confocal
microscopes you can get which I'll be
happy I won't get too much into the
exact tech what is the basis of each of
the technologies but I'll be happy to
answer questions about that or talk
about that offline this is a lot of fun
in terms of how they got to this of
these types of throughput in terms of
number of bases but essentially here you
can see that the mean is about 420 with
a spread in terms of the the actual read
length that you'll achieve with the
newer long read technology we're
expecting this the average mean to go
about seven hundred paces and this type
of technology has been extremely
important in de novo assembly type of
applications with the many non typical
plants and animal model systems that the
genomic skoura cornell processes just to
give you an idea compared to the
traditional type of workflow that you
would need with st. Sanger based
chemistry with the first generation
sequencing on the 454 you can get your
data in about three days two days worth
of a web bench work and one day in terms
of data generation and just to give you
an idea of this type of impact about
five years ago I was involved in a whole
microbial genome assembly of a virulent
strain of pseudomonas
a bacterial genome about 450 million
base genome so we dedicated one ABI 3730
Excel to this project it took us about
10 weeks to get 10x coverage and the
cost of this project including library
prep and data generation was about fifty
thousand dollars now we can do this same
project for the cost of less than a
thousand dollars in less than a day on
our current next-generation sequencing
platforms and that's why it's a
no-brainer why a lot of different types
of projects are being applied to these
new technologies and the technologies
are developing very rapidly you know we
have both the alumina GA 2 X and the the
newest I iteration of that the alumina
hi seek 2000 in the lab we have two of
these units the high seek just came out
as a commercially available project at
the beginning of this year and basically
the difference between these two
instruments which are all related to
density of information and speed of
scanning and such allows you to get
anywhere from five to ten times the
information off of the high seek then
you can get off the ga 2x so you can get
about 50 gigabytes 50 million bases of
data off the g8 2x again this slide is
already outdated we can get about 500
billion bases of the hi-c 2000 and
there's also a real need for doing an
integrated approach with many projects
in terms of using multiple types of
instruments to support a single project
just as an example of this this is a
like to just point out a high density
scorable markers form a straight to
section project which is I've been
involved with which is the lead p I this
is at Butler with the usda-ars here at
Cornell
and doreen we're over at the Cold Spring
Harbor so basically the the idea of this
project was to try to pull out a couple
of million steps out of maze at that
time there wasn't amazed genome
available in the public domain so the
way we went about this is we did a
restriction digest type of approach to
reduce complexity so we got about eighty
percent reduction of complexity that way
and we use these methyl fractions first
on the 454 to build up essentially
reference scaffolds that we could then
use for the much cheaper much faster
aluminum-based runs and very much this
was a very successful project and was
the basis for the technology that at
butlers group has come out with which is
called genotyping by sequencing and
currently using this type of approach
we're able to multiplex 384 samples per
flow channel on an alumina hi-c there
are 16 flow channels on the Lumina hi-c
so we're doing 16 times 384 samples to
do genotyping which reduces the cost of
genotyping to about eight dollars per
sample and you know this has been such a
success successful approach that the
Institute for genetic diversity which is
also under the biotech Institute is now
creating a service dedicated to this and
we have about right now about a dozen
plant based projects and about eight
vertebrate based projects using this
approach which really brings down the
cost of genotyping to enable types of
research that just weren't possible
before so in terms of what this type of
technology can really do the the
Illumina hi seek gives us a real
matic increase in in the cost of
lowering the cost of beta / bass and in
increasing the number of bases per run
so right now what that means that you
can do a human-sized genome on this
instrument in about a week at a cost of
consumable based cost of about five
thousand dollars so this is and this is
basically this charts charts the cost of
doing a human genome which you typically
do at least a 30 x coverage to with this
type of short read technology the cost
per each year to do this so and you can
see that it's been decreasing
dramatically and it's not just doing
whole genome types of projects but you
can do you know as i mentioned before
targeted genomes just look at targeted
regions of interest you can multiplex
molar genomes and you can also do not
Jade not just you know assembly but for
example the types of expressions studies
that you would in previously at would
have really done on micro arrays so you
can do with the alumina high seek up to
200 samples for a two-day run at a
consumable cost that's basically
equivalent to prior microwave types of
studies so the challenges to
implementing this type of new sequencing
technologies really there are many of
them but one of the one of the most
obvious is the large and rapidly
increasing amounts of data on the left
hand here is the number of samples that
have been processed by our sequencing
our genomic score since it was
established in 2002 and this is a linear
scale on the left over here on the right
is the number of bases per year that the
that the genomic score has been putting
out and this is a geometric scale so a
logarithmic scale so as you can see we
constantly increased the blue here the
light blue is the first generation
sequencing and you can see that the next
generation sequencing technology
here in red and green on these bars have
enabled orders of magnitude more data in
terms of what the core is putting out
and if you combine the linear scale of
the number of samples with the
logarithmic scale of the number of bases
it's very easy to deduce that what we're
really doing here is getting a lot more
information per sample so next I'd like
to talk a bit about our proteomics and
mass spec facility so we have a number
of different tools for sample
preparation and in separation including
a number of HPLC units we have two djs
systems and we also have robotics for
gel spot and a gel elution for for the
for the 2d gels we have a number of
tools for data generation as I mentioned
earlier we have all maldito toph which
is an ABI 4700 and we have a number of
electrons spray instruments including
the 4000 cute wrap the senate sinop mass
spec and the orbitrap from of the orbit
ravi lowes from the thermo and we
provide a number of different
bioinformatics tools for analysis
including gel image analysis software
search engines including mascot and
others and we have limbs for data
storage and and and data return this is
our 4000 q trap here is our moldy tov
tov this is the sin app and this is the
instrument that we all really love we
got this in the past year the the
orbitrap which gives us orders of better
resolution and sensitivity than than any
of our prior instruments about it in
comparing these instruments here on a
very general type of axes is the price
is a
the y-axis and capability and
performance is the x-axis the baldy tov
tov is still used but it it's no longer
the you know the instrument of choice
for for many types of research projects
the 4000 q trap and thus in app provide
very good data but in terms of
capability and performance the orbitrap
is is really pushing the envelope and
there are a number of different
considerations we look at when we
compare these types of instruments and
determine which one is the appropriate
one for for any particular research
project and the types of parameters we
look at our sensitivity resolution
accuracy quantitation scan speed mass
range and dynamic range and for any
particular project will sit down with
you and go over which is the right
platform for your particular for the
goals of your particular research
project so the the core provides a
number of different types of services we
provide biomolecular separation and
sample preparation both for 2d gel and
and NH PCH hplc we provide a protein ID
we do comparative proteomics both with
2d gels and I track we do protein
characterization doing put post
translational modification based studies
as as well as looking at other types of
amino acid modifications and we do small
molecule profiling and quantitation we
provide help with the data
interpretation we also provide training
for on various types of techniques the
core has been very very active in
implementing new technologies and this
is just a timeline in terms of the new
technologies that the core has provided
over the past
five years going everywhere from 2d gel
to I track to targeted p TMS and most
recently imac and in tech protein ms
analysis i'd like to also talk a little
bit about our imaging facility so our
imaging facility provides a large range
of different types of technologies
everything from conventional confocal
fluorescence microscopy see to whole
animal fluorescent imaging to
high-resolution ultrasound the thing I'd
like to point out is the latest
technology that we've implemented which
is both micro and nano CT so this is the
same type of CT when you go to a
hospital to get a CT scan but of much
higher resolution so the types of
database data sets that we've been
generating includes everything from
vertebrates to invertebrates plants
electronics fossils anything related to
life sciences types of applications as
well as non life sciences materials
sciences type of applications so our
micro CT capabilities are provide a lot
of different support for a lot of
different types of research projects
including paleontology and botany and
obviously horticulture the advantages of
this type of technology is non-invasive
non-destructive it provides both 3-d and
4-d datasets datasets by 4 d I mean over
time and you can get direct in vivo
measurements so just to give you an
example of this my hope this works ah ok
let's see if I can get this to work
sorry
so this is a three-dimensional
reconstruction of Snapdragon so I
consider this both some of the most
image intensive informative and artistic
type of data that we put out in our core
Center so and this is the type of
technology that we've been looking at
from things you wouldn't imagine looking
at fossils and seeing the internal
structure of turbulence we've been doing
it through tomato and not needing to cut
into tomato and just getting a full
three-dimensional stew very high
resolution structure of the tomato so
these are the types of applications that
we can do in our imaging core
so it also like to focus a little bit in
on the types of services and resources
that our bio dramatics facility can
provide again we call this our
computational biology service unit and
it's typically called just as CBS you so
our project workflow for a lot of our
projects and all of our cores is very
very simple we it's
investigator-initiated we do start up a
project we put the sample data into our
laboratory information management system
we do quality control on the samples
that are submitted in this case so I'm
saying sequencing but for any of these
cores we can do the sample processing
and with the data into our data pipeline
and then do various types of data
analysis and quality control on a daily
weekly monthly and project basis and
that data it can then be distributed
back to the to the investigator and also
sent to the biome ultramatic score for
further downstream chewing on the data
and that again can be distributed back
to the investigator so in more complex
detail just in terms of just for
sequencing we really have a number of
different ways of integrating various
laboratory processes with our laboratory
information management system and the
investigator can then access this data
at various points so our lymph system
provides support from everything from
data archiving to data analysis through
data tracking and as well as data
generation and for example the way our
investigators going to interact with
this when you if you provide samples for
example for a next-generation sequencing
project as I said it can take a week or
more to generate the data off the
instrument and there can be a processing
queue for that as well you really want
to know where your samples are in that
processing queue and that was we got a
lot of feedback from faculty about the
need for that and we've implemented
various
now that faculty can go to our go to our
website and see just for their own
samples where they are in the processing
queue and get a very rough estimate in
terms of what the data return time and
such our biomathematics score provides a
lot of different types of by automatic
pipelines for sequencing it includes
everything from base calling production
qaq sees the sequence alignment and data
visualization and all that goes into
various boxes in terms of the analytical
tools from genome and targeted region
Ricci Qin saying RNA seek chip seek or
custom types of projects now one of the
things that well I should say that these
my automatic pipelines are actually
available on directly to investigators
and the way that's done is through what
we call by ohpc which is a computational
biology application suite for
high-performance computing it's again
this is already outdated here I say we
have 48 software applications were up to
more than 52 software applications that
we're currently providing support for
including data mining population
genetics phylogenetics protein structure
prediction and modeling and actual
next-generation sequencing analysis
pipelines actually all the data that's
generated by our genomics facility for
next-generation sequencing automatically
goes to these pipelines is analyzed and
distributed to the investigator using
these tools and we have tools available
that the investigators can go back and
Rihanna the types of applications that
are on the bio HPC the as I said include
a wide range of applications and here I
just list a small number of them and
we've we basically put on the
applications that the our research
community says would be useful so if
some of these applications could be home
brew types of software packages that
faculty here are developing and the
other
our commercial or freeware type of
applications that the general community
uses now another big focus of our
bioinformatics facility is in education
and training so we have a number of
different workshops covering practical
aspects of using computational biology
applications a in a Linux type of
environment so we have linux for
biologists parts one and two we have one
just using the bio HPC software and we
have how to use the interface so the
workshops are focused on practical
applications of particular techniques
and algorithms in computational biology
last year we started off with just a
general one for example for
next-generation sequencing and we had
about a hundred and sixty students staff
and faculty attend and the feedback we
got is that folks wanted more in-depth
focus on particular topics and we've
responded with that for example by
having a RNA seek workshop recently and
just last week we had a genotyping by
sequencing workshop and we have more
coming up and you'll be able to find out
about those by just going to our website
and I'll give you that information later
training is conducted using the bio HPC
lab the bio HPC laboratory is actually a
collaborative result of the CBS you from
from the core laboratory center the
three CPG the Cornell center for
comparative and population genetics and
the CVG the Cornell vertebrate genomics
group so this has been a very very
useful collaboration all the workshop
materials including lecture slides
exercise walkthrough and the data are
available online so if you missed any of
these you can see the materials and for
future ones you can look at the material
before the actual
jobs we also talked like to talk a
little bit about our advancing so when
we try to think about what new
technologies to bring in from my
viewpoint we really look at it from
three different levels do you want to be
cutting-edge this now being cutting-edge
means that you really need to be able to
bleed a little bit and not die from it
so what we're talking about here is very
early stage implementation of emerging
technologies and flip folks like the
road or Wash U or other large-scale
genome centers are really excellent it
at doing this the road for example I
believe has a room where they've chained
down a half a dozen engineers from life
technologies and don't let them go or
from alumina I should say and don't let
them go in case any of the instruments
break down another way to think about
this is being in the early adopter and
by this I mean a early stage development
of new technologies where you have an
instrument that doesn't break down every
two days but when the vendor is
releasing it it really hasn't been
optimized in terms of the best way to do
the existing applications or really been
explored in terms of the full range of
new applications you could put on this
and that's actually an ideal sweet spot
for our core laboratory center we do a
lot of this both in collaboration with
instrument vendors as well as with
faculty on this campus and other
campuses of Cordell and the third level
is really the level of a conventional
user where you want an instrument that
your most important consideration is
that it's giving you good high quality
data with the instruments never breaking
down and that's the main consideration
of a lot of core facilities are typical
academic core facilities you really just
want to be able to robustly generate the
data so when we look at Advanced
Technology Assessment one of the big
focus areas is on third generation
sequencing technologies
one of them that we've been really
focusing on is the pack biotechnology
from a company called Pacific biosystems
which is actually a spinoff from Cornell
this technology was developed here what
web was one of the major developers
Howard craighead who is the head of the
nano biotechnology a center here was one
of the developers um so this was just
commercially released recently the you
can get a relent on this instrument on
average read lengths of 1500 contiguous
basis with the ninety-fifth percentile
going out to about 3,000 a contiguous
bases and it's possible to get even more
by pushing the instrument to get as much
as 10,000 basis of contiguous read so
again already this slide is outdated
they now get about 75,000 bases read /
run in parallel so you're getting about
75 million bases per run it only takes
about an hour or so to do a run with
with a reagent cost of about a hundred
dollars so it's very cheap very fast to
run it's you know in comparison to the
massively parallel second generation
sequencing technologies that we have
here you can think of this as having
some ideals applications that will
enable new types of research projects
that weren't really possible before
these types of long redlands for example
are ideal in terms of looking at snv's
structural structural variant components
by that i mean insertions deletions
duplications and inversions which are
very difficult to see with small with
small reads with short base reads and
this type of long read technology is
also very good to do in a hybrid sense
with the shorter reads to add
information to allow assembly
should say this technology is also the
pack bio technology is advancing rapidly
by the end of the year the average read
lengths are expected to be about three
thousand bases with the ninety-fifth
percentile going out to six to nine
thousand bases and with contiguous reads
being able to be pushed out to maybe
15,000 to 20,000 basis so we currently
have a pack bio at Cornell it was
received about two months ago at the
only wild cornell medical school campus
in new york city and it's being set up
as its own sequencing core and we hope
that but it's it was brought together by
a group of investigators that will get
primary access it will be a traditional
type of of Korra access but any excess
capacity will be available to the
community at large and if folks want to
utilize this you can just get in contact
wheat with me and I'll be happy to put
you in touch with the folks down at the
medical school that are to help make
sure that it will be an effective core
and we have a number of different
efforts to try to bring in the pack bio
to the Ithaca campus the types of
applications that you might be able to
do in plant biology well I could go on
but on and on about that but I think you
guys could be tell me much more in terms
of the types of unique applications just
very briefly the way this technology
works is that you have an ANA fabricated
hole on a metal film that's on top of a
silica base and the poor width size is
only enough to allow epi luminescence
through there you have a polymerase
that's attached to the bottom of this
poor and you're reading the strand of
DNA as it goes through the DNA has each
of the nucleotides has in a base at the
very end and I'm sorry a fluorescent dye
marker at the very end of the phosphate
change chain and that is cut off after
incorporation so at the end you have
a natural strand of DNA which doesn't
have any of the types of the types of
tertiary structure types of problems
that you can get with other types of
incorporation of die terminators for
example in Sanger base chemistry very
nice thing about this technology is that
besides putting in that since you're
using a polymerase what they have found
is that you can detect modified bases by
the amount of time that the that the
nucleotides actually hang at the point
of incorporation inside the polymerase
so basically you can use kinetics to
detect modified DNA bases and that's the
basis of detection for four simultaneous
DNA sequencing and methylation based
detection and you can detect not just
methylated basis but any type of any
type of base modification you could also
instead of putting down a polymerase put
down a reverse transcriptase and do
direct RNA sequencing so instead of as
what now with as you do with
next-generation sequencing where you do
you you take your RNA you convert it
into the complementary DNA and run that
on your sequencer you can do direct
sequencing of that RNA transcript which
means that you have fewer steps where
you can introduce artefactual embrace or
reverse transcriptase you could put down
a transcript transcriptome I'm sorry as
a spice is ohm or a or a ribosome and so
you can look at splicing or you can look
at protein sequencing peptide see
sequencing so there are a lot of
different types of applications say
currently the commercially available
application is direct DNA sequencing but
these other applications have already
been published and shown improve of
concept and we'd like to get our hands
on this instrument to really push these
applications in collaboration with with
faculty and with the nano fab folks and
other folks
at Cornell I should say that since
you're doing true single molecule
sequencing on this instrument for
standard sequencing where you're just
doing one pass sequencing you're only
getting about eighty-five percent
accuracy but the sample prep is
basically you create a circular
structure and you can do multiple reads
of the same circulars of product and by
in that way increase your accuracy to
close two levels of others other types
of sequencing technology platforms
another very new sequencing technology
that's come out is the Ion Torrent this
is the first true non-optical sequencing
technology essentially it's built on a
computer chip which is pictured over
here this cuter the computer chip has as
matta fabricated massively parallel PH
meters on it at the bottom you're
essentially doing sequencing within each
well and you're detecting the release of
the hydrogen ion at the time of base
incorporation so the nice thing about
this technology since it's based
essentially on CMOS technology it has
very fast cycling times in terms of
development this technology came out
less than a year ago with hundred based
reads it's now doing 500 based reads
it's doing about ten thousand reads in
parallel and at a cost for a single run
which takes about 20 to 24 hours reagent
based cost of about five hundred dollars
and the instrument itself is less than a
hundred thousand dollars as compared to
the high seek the alumina high seek or
the pacbio both of which are about three
quarters of a million dollars so this is
a very very nice new platform that we're
hoping to bring in here as well and
we're talking to faculty about who's
interested who might be able to help us
acquire this and we're looking at
various
grant funding mechanisms as well I
should say again down in the medical
school they've just received an Ion
Torrent that's available again to
anybody at Cornell so that if you do
want to do a first pass test of this
technology you are able to send samples
down to the medical school for that so I
will go into big detail about this but
essentially what we're talking about is
in terms of the types of genomic
technologies we have first-generation a
number of different second generation
technologies and we're trying to bring
in a number of third generation
technologies and the potential projects
using these emerging sequencing
technologies run the gamut everything
from application of sequencing by
genotyping to breeding conservation and
global species in population surveys
sequencing of individual human genomes
as part of personalized medicine de novo
global gene expression analysis based
types of projects identification of
microbial diversity for agricultural
environmental and therapeutic goals and
things that folks haven't yet done but
are thinking about for example DNA
computing manipulating DNA libraries for
highly parallel computations so you know
the second generation sequencing
technologies were really looking at
doing the goal which with of these
technologies was doing a mammalian human
sized genome at the cost of ten thousand
to a hundred thousand dollars which is
about four words of magnitude less than
the human genome project did of for
their for their end goal third
generation sequencing technologies have
the real potential of doing a human
mammalian size genome at the cost of a
thousand dollars or less and that price
point is being reached very rapidly and
you know there are a number of different
approaches for that I mentioned the pack
bio which that technology is based on
what's called the zero mode waveguides
which are those nana fabricated pores
that i had mentioned but there are other
approaches as well for example nanopores
pulling DNA through a poor in a silica
base and reading it as it goes through
now at that level of that has a lot of
challenges at that level of detection
your detectors can interfere with your
detection and also the speed in which
DNA can translocate through a poor can
be very fast and a challenge to single
base resolution but a lot of clever
folks are coming up to clever solutions
to this one of the most prominent
companies that are working on this is
Oxford nanopore and where eventually
either in the coming year definitely
within the next two to three years this
will be a very very viable and very very
exciting a technology that will be
commercially available so our problem is
how soon we have to buy our next new toy
and what new challenges with these new
platforms now finally I just want to end
up talking about finding information
about core facilities so in the arc core
Center we do a number of different
things we have our website we have
department we try to give talks at these
types of departmental seminars we run
training workshops but they're each of
the course has their own training
workshops a number of the cores have
user group meetings and we have
technology based seminars for example we
have a life sciences advanced technology
seminar series where we try to bring in
folks either vendors or folks using new
technologies to to make to bring these
new paradigms and new technologies
research community we send out user
surveys and we have a lot of faculty
involvement each of our core facilities
has a faculty advisory board that
provides feedback as to the value and
those future directions of our cores and
we currently have more than 50 for
faculty from 20 departments in six
colleges at Cornell combined on these
various faculty advisory boards we also
have a number of educational workshops I
had mentioned about the bioinformatics
core workshops including the
next-generation sequencing workshop and
the bioinformatics core of bio HPC
laboratory our proteomics and mass spec
core runs a proteomics workshop
and is also as meetings of the Cornell
proteomics program and you know as I had
mentioned we have a advanced technology
seminar series we have various user
meetings for our genomic score as well
as a list server and confluent site
where users can share not just as an
email you know discussion but share
software share publications and share
protocols that they're developing and
our I had mentioned the Cornell
proteomics program which is supported by
our proteomics in mass spec [ __ ] and
our imaging Corps has the big group the
bioimaging group when they have a
seminar series associated with that we
try to bring in have presentations by
all the four directors in September we
had an expo where we brought up all the
cores from the Medical School and they
had a combined poster Expo with the
older course from the Ithaca campus
we're working with vivo so that which
most of you are probably aware is a
search engine for Cornell so we're
trying to make it so that if you put
down genotyping and get not just the
faculty that are working with genotyping
but all that have their genotyping
resources and services and where their
locations are in such so this is still a
work in progress but we do have vivo
does currently do some of this and I
want to tell us i mentioned all the
course at at Cornell and this is a
represented but not exhaustive list of
the course though I've talked a lot
about our life sciences core laboratory
center with our seven course but there
are other cores as well that are either
departmental focus or a school focus or
a single campus wide focus and those
include the nano biotechnology Center
the CNF the CCM are as
the flow core in the vet school there's
an NMR core a statistical consulting
unit and a number of other shared
resource services and centers located on
Ithaca as well as a number of different
core facilities about 14 down at the
cornell medical college the the coterie
campus has been increasing the number of
course until recently they the date the
date palm genome assembly as well as in
medical based types of projects they
also now have a proteomics and
bioinformatics cores as well and there
are various library resources as well
that helped you identify these types of
core resources in terms of finding out
cores outside of Cornell I just want to
point out that there's a the ABR F the
association of biomolecular resource
facilities has both white pages and
yellow pages that identify more than 250
Core labs that are members of this
international association of core
facilities and there are a number of
registries of core facilities include
besides the ABR F the Vermont genetic
network in the am deck which is a
consortium of 26 institutions in New
York State all have their own core
facilities databases to help you find
out if you know if Cornell doesn't offer
a if Cornell doesn't offer it and you
need it you should be coming to us as
well and letting us know we have a
process whereby faculty can request new
cores to become part of our Center
either existing cores departmental
course that might have a value as a
university-wide resource or new course
based on new technologies and obviously
you know in the current economic
environment we're limited in terms of
the number of course we can bring under
our umbrella but we do need to hear from
faculty as to what would be the best
thing for us to do finally I want to say
you know the whole idea of running cores
offering horses to network with faculty
staff
and students and that's why I'm here and
as nature has taught us networking can
provide very very many productive
results so I'd like to end up with
acknowledging the folks at the core
laboratory center all the core facility
directors including Peter Schweitzer the
director of our genomic score James
vandy the director of our bio whitey
core Shen Zheng the director of our mass
spec core Yara clock and Becky Williams
the director of our imaging course we
have primary faculty advisors for each
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu